[Music]
so
there was this guy named travis
who created an account on poor hub
pornhub a poor hub where all the poor
people beat
where we talk about wic oh the step
brothers and step sisters at all poor
talk about wick and edd and how to make
sure your ebt
card uh looks legit yeah sounds like a
very lucrative
website poor hub you have to go to
starbucks to log in
yeah oh
dollar tree has their janky wi-fi
outside that's where we gotta go
i don't know i believed you oh it's okay
and you also believe poor hub's a thing
so
no i i like that idea no okay so pornhub
he created an account
on pornhub and he named it
mad butcher nz so mad butcher
is cutting up that meat say
it's a a franchise like butchery kind of
oh oh
oh franchise butcher shop yes in nz like
new zealand
um so they're all over the place
actually there's one in san francisco i
googled or sacramento yeah
um anyway so he created this account on
pornhub
and this is what he commented on one of
the videos
he commented holy moly that girl really
does love her meats and so do we
that's why this week we're offering
fresh
chicken breasts only 9.99 a kilo i
would've gone immediately
just can't beat the mad butcher's meat
oh my god
talk about taking advertising to another
level that's
i love about you beat your meat yeah
come slim jim slim jim's on it
on all the meme pages are they they're
the first one to comment on every moon
picture who
who's slim jim the jerky break into a
slim jig yeah those guys
they have an instagram page but it seems
like so personable
they make some funny jokes yeah yeah oh
do they have a pornhub account
they probably might i don't know dog
think jim thick gym
so this dude posted this right and
that's when
mad butcher's chief executive
ended up having to make a comment and
say we have nothing to do with this
so did he comment under that comment and
he says as the chief executive
of he had to log in i know he's all
logging off
create his account he's so mad he's like
oh
the account he's had for ten years oh
this is bad for our branding
and then it says like account created in
1994 or some [ __ ] like that you're like
oh why the [ __ ] is that there can't you
go like i could log in and create one if
nobody's taking it mcdonald's that's
exactly what
what mad butcher was saying he's like
with social media platforms today these
types of posts can be done quite easily
and you have
no control over them and what is posted
uh and then he also said the large
majority of people will know mad butcher
would never revert to a porn site to
advertise
plus that's nice our special price for
chicken breast is well under 9.99 per
kilo
it looks like first off [ __ ] get the
price right exactly maybe it was a
marketing ploy because you could tell
the actual prices
yeah maybe it was his competitor oh
mastermind going in no but that would
help them
no but who knows because now they have a
whole publicity [ __ ] but then that's
giving them more battle business that's
true
this is actually this game this is good
publicity it's brilliant yeah like he
hired someone to do this and
only for him to come up like we had
nothing to do with it that's mad genius
right there there you go
is that working are they getting hella
sales yeah i don't know i wanna
we're talking about it so they're gonna
find the place now if you if if you see
this video
obviously if you're watching this video
you see me talking about it but go there
and
buy their meat yeah are you looking for
an endorsement
i know yes i would love it i was like
so if you wanna so you're pretty much
saying if you want to give me your meat
go and look at them yes but jk news
incentives
point upside you when's the last time
you went to a butcher shop like last
week
i used to get me from butcher box that
was pretty cool what's that oh they just
send it to you send you a bunch of you
it's like a subscription
uh meat service and they'll give you
like all kinds of meatballs frozen meat
yeah but i want like elk and bison and
that kind of stuff what kind of meat can
you not live without
if you had to choose one meat beef beef
they or what do you what's your question
oh my god like one meat that you eat
forever
beef yeah like like if it's like tuna
meat
deer meat beef meat tuna tuna
it counts as meat yeah yeah fish meat
fish meats yeah salmon meat
fresh lives all matter i'm not saying
that usually when meat
it's like referred to like red meat is
other meat
meat yeah chicken chicken meat muscle
fibers how about that for me it's beef i
love beef too much me too man
i can't go without which cut it's a rib
eye for me i don't know just beef
if you had to choose one cut i had to
choose
to choose one cut oh my god what's the
shabu shabu cut
they have chalk that's delicious
they have rib eyes that cut from angus
and uh but english isn't a cut right no
no it's a it's a type of
cow yeah but it's usually chuck or it's
usually uh ribeye those are the top
i could live without meat for the rest
of it i'm going ahi i can't go with that
you're a fish person yeah i like meat
[Music]
but i also like fish too yeah if
anything i'd probably
pick fish out of anything okay now pick
your favorite fish
my favorite fish salmon no no it used to
be salmon and then i had too much salmon
i got sick of salmon i was like i can't
do salmon anymore and then i went over
to yellowtail
tell tells my [ __ ] but then like tuna i
feel like
mm-hmm how much is so good maybe i would
pick yellowtail over tuna but it's
between the two of them for me
good choice pig chicken chicken no
chicken sucks
chicken now but chicken's diverse though
you got dark meat and white meat you
if you want diet take pictures for me
chicken i would pick chicken
chicken is honestly on the bottom of my
list really
chicken is tasteless bro i'm doing ahi
dude you don't know how to make [ __ ]
chicken then
no i'm saying the chicken by itself
chicken is good i like chicken
chicken is flavored that's true if i do
high man chicken and then my favorite
broth is chicken broth too
it's true yeah but you can do a lot but
chicken is versatile but if i have to go
i'm going like i can eat
ahi every day and i've tried it and i
can chicken i could go without steak i
can go without is there different kinds
of tuna
oh tons of different tons tons of
different types but
your favorite i'm just go i mean that's
just the realistically
i can eat that ahi tuna i can eat that i
could doctor it up i could eat it raw i
can cook it whatever but that's true
chicken is good but if again i could do
without it if you're like last meal
yeah for a while that's a different
question then last one less meat
less meat for a while no more meats for
you yeah like if you had to choose one
meat and you had to eat that for
a long time doing ahi i can i can
literally i can eat that ever that's
true yeah because meat like beef can get
a little
heavy heavy and you feel you feel kind
of depends on
how you cooking how you're preparing
what you're eating if i had to go for
several months i'm going
whole couch i have options yeah smart
you could do broth you could do whatever
yeah yeah true yeah but it's something i
could eat realistically
i probably can go pesticide
i can go carnivore more than i can go
vegan
vegan that's it begins to a different
vegan is intense all respected
i love my dairy too much i could do
carnivore way easier than i could do i
respect anybody that like
likes what they like for real if you are
so strong in what you like and that's a
thing and it has a name do you
hasn't it you know if it has a name
because i'm not committed i'm not going
to fight nobody off of what they like
[ __ ] just because i don't want to eat
you know substitute cheese all the damn
time
this just what do you call junktarians
junktarians americans
but junk are they just called americans
oh
pretty much have you ever stopped eating
something and you felt completely
different after like you cut back on
faster oh i went
keto yeah you went keto cut out carbs
cut out sugar and i was like addicted to
chocolate chip cookies
so the first month it's like you're
literally like something
they're right there we had some today no
today yeah it's fine oh i'm addicted so
i
got back on it but he's like i got a
[ __ ]
cookie monster after the first month to
be a cookie monster for halloween i
should you should
after the first month you you're like
it's like a new world
and you see it and you're like huh yeah
that's it yeah i saw him
say whatever that was me with tahin
but he's not bad what you mean is like
so sodium huh you want like this
something's not bad for you yeah like
i'm sorry what you just said
much is bad for you [ __ ] yeah your diet
but like you need salt
but you don't need to eat it you don't
need too much addicted to tahini
well you've been hanging out with too
many polly's lying to you that's why
they all got gout that's why they all
got diabetes high blood pressure
mayonnaise
and eating that but omega-3s are in
mayonnaise yeah we'll talk about the
omega-3 benefits
my friend will literally go home and
we're like what are we going to eat and
he just gets saltine crackers and
mayonnaise
yeah is he white no he's polynesian but
that's what don't take any dating
like diet devices or dating or diet
we're [ __ ]
psycho and big like we all got diabetes
glaucoma yeah but i don't know so taking
is bad
yeah no i had i had the little mini one
in my purse and
i would like it was good on watermelon i
would i would
treat him yeah i would raise like my my
crack or something because i remember
being stressed
and like [ __ ] what was it in traffic
i'd be stressed in traffic and i cuz i
had one in my purse
and in my car so i would bring out the
one in my car i'll take like a little
shot
like a little bump that's why your
ankles were swelling
you had high sodium that's that's
addiction hypertension
i didn't know you were serious but i was
like
i occasionally like to keep a whole tub
of [ __ ] tahini in my purse and eat it
on the road i thought i was like oh
i'm eating fruit i'm like nah i have to
put this
straight up i don't know i was driving
in traffic i'm [ __ ] cracked out i'm
like
yeah that was her but say that are you
that one
he's she been trying to tell you i'm
addicted like
you dude but you said you were addicted
to cookies and nobody questioned you
exactly what did you think i was in
[ __ ] chocolate yes yes
that's what i thought you're
appropriating to learn addiction you put
this in my face
that's why we said you had a problem now
you don't you said it's a whole new
world now
yeah we thought you were cookie monster
yeah i said cookies oh yes
yeah what the [ __ ] you guys need to
chill on your versions you need to
choose the right words
people gotta read the word all wrong i
can't even back you up there dude
no but taking okay i get like if you
were like yo i had to put that shot on
everything like it's [ __ ]
like red hot sauce that still wouldn't
be addicted that's a fiction no she's
addicted actually like literally i'd be
like
[ __ ] everything you're like on the
tlc show where they're like i can only
eat mac and cheese exactly
my stranger okay now wait a question now
explain your cookie addiction because
now you're done
now we're thinking that it's not an
addiction you're not addicted to it i
would go to 7-eleven every single day
and get like two chocolate chip cookies
oh my gosh that's a habit it's a habit
it's a habit
everybody grab their [ __ ] dress
that's a coffee hat
i'm like oh [ __ ] it's like late at night
i'm like let me get my car and i'll go
drive there an addiction would be
yes i mean right here on the table and
she would probably be like salivating
yes yes yes
dude those elevated we already said that
i'm gonna retract my statement okay good
addiction finally use the right words
for the people that are addicted to
tahini and chocolate cookies for real
yeah i apologize yeah don't offend us
i'm sorry that uh
me voicing this has triggered you in any
type of work you need to have a crumbled
piece of half cookie in your pocket
pocket to be
yeah you take one bite out of it and put
it back yeah you don't even know how old
it is you don't know you've eaten it
no matter what yep yep that was last
night
then you already did i opened the drawer
that was a cookie i was like [ __ ] and i
was
i started my diet did you eat it and not
my diet today because i had that what
kind of cookie do you like
it was seven chocolate chip is the best
cookie shit's pretty good
the seven of chocolate chip cookies what
about their sticker do you like this
that's snickerdoodle it's so
good it's good i don't know
just kidding but i envisioned like
literally you staring in mouth water
that's what i'm having you were doing
about cookies that's why we felt bad
they were
[Music]
you